[Music]
good evening a big relief for thousands
across the state tonight as governor
siselek
extends nevada's eviction moratorium
thanks for joining us here at six i'm
denise valdez
and i'm kirsten joyce we do have team
coverage this evening
let's move forward with joe moeller who
is live with reaction from renters
but we are actually going to start with
oracle mana who is live outside the
grant
sawyer building orco
well the moratorium on evictions was
supposed to expire tomorrow but governor
sistel act
is now extending it by 45 days he says
this will give the state and counties
more time
to get much-needed help to nevadans now
we know thousands of you
have been struggling in the wake of
coven 19 because you've lost your jobs
and it's hard to pay rent or mortgage
and for months the state ordered banning
evictions helped you keep those homes
this 45-day extension will allow
counties to pay out short-term rental
assistance
to landlords and governor sisalak has
approved an additional 10 million
dollars
to help with rental assistance
additionally the state will use these 45
days
to continue reducing the backlog of
unemployment claims
it'll also give the courts more time to
put in place a new mediation program
which is meant to bring landlords
and tenants together to resolve any
disputes and avoid evictions down the
road
the governor saying he wishes this help
was available now
i'm disappointed that the court could
not get the mediation program in place
quicker
but they couldn't and then when you've
got to face what i'm dealing with with
the social delivery service social
service delivery partners
that are saying i don't want a hundred
thousand people lined up over here at
catholic charities trying to get help
governor sysolak says he is waiving
certain requirements
in the hopes that the landlord tenant
mediation program can be up and running
by the end of september now as far as
processing those unemployment claims go
governor sisolak says that he and his
office as well as theater are working
around the clock
to resolve those issues and he says that
those 45 days
will be instrumental in making some
progress and he also says
that 5 000 people will be getting their
benefits this week
reporting live orgomana 8 news now